hundreds of prisoners stripped to their
shorts and forced to sit packed tightly
together regarded by Honduran military
police on Monday after the country's
government promised a harsh Crackdown on
criminal gangs operating Behind Bars the
military takeover of the country's
severely overcrowded and gang-infested
prison system came after two births of
lethal violence shocked the country
first on June 21st members of a gang in
a women's prison attacked other inmates
with smuggled guns knives and flammable
liquids killing at least 46 women some
of whom were burned alive
their remains were so badly damaged
authorities could not immediately
identify them delaying notification of
the Dead inmates relatives
Honduran president xiomara Castro said
she was shocked by what she called
monstrous murders but there were more
killings to come
on Sunday gunmen burst into a pool hall
and opened fire killing 11 people
authorities indicated the slaughter may
have been some sort of Revenge for the
women's prison massacre
on Monday the country's military was
handed control of the prison system and
began searching cell blocks for weapons
authorities promised new laws to
facilitate stronger measures
in the next few days a proposal will be
sent to National Congress to label the
members of criminal structures or gangs
as terrorists
Honduran military police officers
displayed weapons and ammunitions seized
inside one of the prisons
if this is what we found in the maximum
security area then you can imagine what
there will be in the rest of the places
criminal gangs have flourished in
several Central American countries for
years killing kidnapping dealing drugs
and leaving many residents afraid to
leave their homes
young people in those areas see no hope
for the future they either join the
gangs or migrate or become part of the
problem so I mean it really is not just
a simple matter of sending in the
military and re-establishing control and
it all goes away
neighboring El Salvador launched a
massive Crackdown last year imprisoning
sixty thousand alleged gang members the
move sparked criticism of Human Rights
abuses but the security situation
improved dramatically now Honduras may
be following the same course Rob
Reynolds Al Jazeera